hello everyone and welcome to the most
important tournament
there is and ever was it is of course
the candidates tournament and we are
back in yekaterinburg uh
with the second half of the candidates
tournament the first half finished last
year
and then uh well due to the situation in
the world we had to uh
well postponed the tournament
indefinitely and now it is finally being
continued so seven rounds have been
played we're gonna see seven more rounds
and uh if you don't remember
uh this is where we left it off so the
leaders uh when we left it off last year
uh in march uh where maxim bashar
al-agrav and yani pomishi who had shared
first place
uh with four and a half out of seven
points followed by
uh with three and a half points fabiano
karwana anishigiri and
van gaal and end with two and a half
points dingling and kirill alexander the
the the new guy uh amongst the the the
the big guys uh so here uh
fabi versus maxima shiela graph is the
first game that we are going to show
from the second half of the candidates
tournament
and it is a really wild one it is uh you
will suffer
while watching this game i guarantee you
that so uh best just
uh let's just dive straight into it and
uh for those of you who don't remember
uh the candidates tournament is being
played with 100 minutes uh for the first
40 moves then we have 50 minutes for the
next 20 moves
and then 15 minutes to the end of the
game with a 30 seconds
increment starting from move one so now
the games can take quite a while
and this one most certainly did so uh
once again let's check it out fabi with
the white pieces opens with e4
and everyone was wondering with maxime
having so long to prepare
uh will he stick to his sicilian defense
or will he try something else against e4
and of course the maxim goes for c5 he
plays the sicilian defense
as he always does we have knight to f3
by fabi
d6 and now d4 striking in the center we
have captures captures
and now knight to f6 we have knight to
c3 and of course a6 maxim goes for the
neither
variation of the sicilian we have bishop
to g5
and now e6 preparing to play bishop to
e7 castle and so on and here we have f4
by fabi
uh asking maxim how do you want to
continue with the usual bishop to e7
uh or do you want to go pawn grabbing as
you well pretty much
always do and maxime continues with
queen to b6 he says
i'm very much interested in your b2 pawn
and well
i don't mind being up material even if
it cost me some development in the
in the opening fabi has says all right
go on
a queen to d2 have that b2 pawn and here
queen captures on b2 and this is all
very standard theory there's nothing new
about this
uh we have rook to b1 attacking the
queen queen to a3
and now of course striking in the center
with e5
so the knight is under attack and also
you are putting some pressure on d6
so here uh while you could go for the
captures on e5 maxine goes for h6 first
with bishop to h4
and only now d captures an e5 in even
though g5 here is a possibility but it's
uh
it's a very tricky line for example
captures uh or rather not
that it captures on g5 first and after h
captures bishop captures now we're going
to move the knight
and after for example bishop to f4 you
can't really
say that black has uh well all that much
compensation for this
not really so while it can be played
maybe not for such a serious game
as one being played in the candidates
tournament so instead d captures an e5
f captures an e5 and now knight f to d7
even though now
g5 is uh is a perfectly viable option so
knight f
the d7 and now comes knight to e4 so
fabi up getting his pieces closer to the
black king
and it's very easy to go wrong here and
many people have gone wrong here for
example if you just continue development
let's say knight to c6 you put pressure
on white's
d for knight simply knight characters b
captures and now bishop to e2 and you
have a lot of problems here
uh just to show you that uh it's uh
extremely difficult for black to develop
here
let's say you try bishop c5 a very
natural developing move you prevent the
white king from castling
rook to b3 you push the black queen back
and after let's say
queen captures on a2 now you run into
knight captures and
uh you're you're just lost here because
if you capture back then queen to d8 is
checkmate
so this is only uh some of the things
that can go wrong but of course maximo
is the absolute strongest idea here and
that is queen captures an e2
on a2 and now the rook on b1 is under
attack so rook to d1
and now queen back to d5 and here maxime
says all right i've grabbed some
material
i now have passed a pawn and look at
this rook behind the past pawn if i can
get this passport rolling down the board
uh you will be in a lot of trouble but i
first have to you know survive not being
checkmated
uh so queen to e3 uh and now
uh fabi asks all right your queen is now
nicely aligned with my rook if i move my
knight let's say
some knight's death uh whoa sorry about
that some night the f5 action opening up
a discovery then maybe knight comes to
d6 and you know
who knows what might happen so queen
captures an e5 maxine
grabs yet another pawn to get the queen
out of the
out of the d file uh and now the
position has been reached before uh
moves like bishop to g3 are known
as going after the queen bishop to e2 is
no move but here we have c3 by fabi just
adding a defender here
and it is only now as of move 16 that we
have a completely new game
so let's see how maxine deals with this
maxim starts by developing he plays
bishop to c5
and he says all right maybe in such an
open game
usually you don't want to trade the
bishop pair but here he is already up
material so he really doesn't mind uh
something like uh well
uh and and it's not even possible here
because the queen on e3 is undefended so
bishop to c5
uh definitely makes sense with bishop to
g3 pushing maxine's queen back
and now queen to d5 has to go uh here
because if you try something like an in
between sufficient to
uh with something like bishop captures
on d4 then you get
rook captures and now you're in a lot of
trouble because after the queen moves
just
knight to d6 check and either you're
losing the bishop here or if the king
defends the knight f7
check picks up the rook so you're losing
something so instead after bishop to g3
we have queen back to d5 again the only
good move for maxime even though it
aligns uh right with
the rook but it doesn't matter and here
maxime is asking all right what's your
what's your compensation here do you
even have a plan here
i mean it's not like you have a move you
can't really move the knight the queen
falls uh
none of your other pieces are doing all
that much if i castle that's it you
don't really have an attack here
and here fabi plays the move uh such a
such a wild move
the move from the thumbnail uh and that
is
bishop to c4 and this is just wonderful
stuff uh such
such wonderful preparation and fabi
played pretty much not pretty much fun
we played all of his moves instantly
up until this point and even further as
you'll see so here the question is
what do you do uh do you accept this
very nice gift or do you move the queen
problem is if you move the queen
then you run into ideas like bishop to
b6 and you are worse for the rest of the
game not just worse you are
you are lost uh the king is never
leaving here
uh there's already a lot of pressure on
this on this bishop here and
you really can't even find a move that
that that is playable here
so you have to watch out for ideas like
this so instead after bishop to c4
uh maxim says all right let's see what
you got queen captures on c4 and now
comes bishop to d6 and this is favi's
idea
and as you'll see it's quite uh quite a
tricky one the problem is of course you
cannot capture the bishop just knight
captures with check and of course you
win the queen
another thing uh if you try what else
can you try if you just continue
development
knights the c6 uh runs into bishop
captures on c5
and now again what do you play if knight
captures then again uh you've uh
released the d6 square and now the
knight can deliver this very nice fork
a royal fork if you will and again white
wings and another thing
uh you might consider okay let's just go
back with the bishop so
we don't run into anything and if any
bishop captures nba trying to move the
light square bishop with tempo trying to
free up the d6 square for the white
knight
then it doesn't work because now our
bishop guards this square the problem is
if you go bishop to a7
then we can just move to b4 and still
prevent black from castling
black will not lose all that much
material here but it will be
it will be very difficult to play and
black can even go for some uh very
tricky queen captures on b4 ideas here
for example c
captures and castles and uh i don't know
seems like uh seems like an idea that
maksim even might go for
uh but not maybe not for uh for a game
that's pla
being played in the candidates
tournament not one that is uh you know
to decide
the the challenger to the world champion
so instead after bishop to the sixth
maxime goes for
knight to f6 he has to give back
material and
fabi gladly accepts here we have knight
captures on c5
and now comes maxim's idea that knight
to d5 attacking fabi's queen on e3 queen
to e5 now putting pressure on g7 and
look at this
look at this pile up here this is just
uh incredible i mean it's hard to
it's hard to imagine that you would
willingly go into this with the black
pieces but this is what maksim does this
is what he always
does sometimes it goes well sometimes it
doesn't but
he always goes for it and you can be
sure about that something that uh also
now i was very very very much
characteristic of bobby fischer you
always knew what bobby fischer would
play you always knew the exact line that
he was going to play
um most of the times even the exact move
order but you were just helpless
against it uh so here uh defending the
g7 pawn would rook the g8
and now comes fabi's idea it's time to
start sacrificing something so here
he comes knight d captures an e6
and this has to be accepted otherwise
this knight will just wreak
havoc here so here uh f captures an e6
and now
the other knight captures as well knight
captures an e6 and now you can't really
uh capture further because if this then
captures with check and if king d8
then you can either pick up the rook or
you can even play rook captures on d5
and now you really don't have
any com uh you know uh contra play here
uh
any checks will very quickly be met with
uh you know
you will very quickly get out of checks
you can block with the rug and then
it's just uh you know uh you're getting
checkmated very quickly
so instead after knight captures an e6
uh
we have the only move available to black
that's uh well that's actually good
uh you you could try to gamble it with
ideas like knight to f6 but i mean
who who does this uh so instead queen
captures on c3 with
check here he forces a queen trade queen
captures on c3
knight captures and now finally fabi
finishes it off with
knight to c7 check and this is not
winning the rook so king to f7 getting
out of the way
and now comes rook to d3 of course
white's rook is also under attack so
rook to d3
and here maxim has a choice and he has
to
he has to play something and now his
rook is hanging and he could play
rook to a7 and rook to a7 seems like a
reasonable thing to do you play rook a7
uh you give up the the knight on c3 and
then we just go let's see king g6 king
to h7
for example white will castle that's why
we move the king king h7 and now you
could let's say go bishop c5
attack the rook and then let's say you
either give up the rook which makes no
sense
or you have to start giving back pawns
b6 bishop captures on b6
and so on maybe play rook to b7 and try
and continue playing
this game uh with your position being a
bit more passive you are up upon but
your position is a bit more passive
uh however maksim never takes the easy
way out after this rook to d3 maksim
doesn't defend his rook with rook to a7
uh rather maxine just plays knight to e4
and this is the
first move where fabi actually started
thinking
uh the situation on the clock is a
minute and uh one hour and 43 minutes
for fabi and only 32 minutes for maxine
and that's really really insane so up
until this point it's been pure
preparation from fabi's side and we're
only on move 26 so we still need to make
14 more moves to reach time control
uh so maxine can get a little bit more
time
and here well you could grab the rook
right away for example a knight captures
an a8
then we run into knight captures on d6
rook captures on d6
and now something like king to e7 not
allowing
this rook to remain here also you don't
want to uh face castles with
check and now if we see something like
rook g6 we might even see a repetition
of moves here king e7 rook g6
and so on rook g6 with the idea of this
rook being uh
well unable to get into the game because
the g7 pawn would be hanging
so instead after this knight the e4 uh
fabi first
goes for castles of course this comes
with check we have
king to g6 you could also block with the
knight
maxine prefers to keep his knight active
on e4 so king the g6
and only now fabi grabs the rook we have
knight capture 78
and now comes knight to c6 here uh
maxine
missed a bit of a well a bit of a more
precise
rook to d8 uh simply because the
there's a lot a lot of pressure here on
the bishop and then after rook after d1
then you go knight to c6 this is the
correct move order uh for you to do
things but he played knight
to c6 right away and this allowed fabi
to
uh well it puts to put a lot of problems
his way so here fabi goes knight to b6
now puts pressure on this bishop uh and
here uh
you should probably play something like
bishop to f5 but maxime
continued with rook to d8 like it was
the the same line
and now he allows fabi this knight
captures on c8
and okay knight captures with rook
captures and now bishop back the e
bishop back to a3 another very
interesting idea is
rook to e1 just putting pressure on this
knight and now
the knight has to go somewhere probably
to g5 and white to retains a very active
position
uh problem is if you go after the bishop
then captures with
check king h7 and now rook to d7 this is
now
obviously very strong the b7 pawn is
under attack if you go for this then
rook c7
and pretty much black's position is
paralyzed you can't move the pawn
because the knight hangs
if you move the knight then you allow
doubling of the rooks here so
it would be um well probably probably a
winning position for example if a5
you start pushing this pawn just rookie
three and that that pawn is not going
very far
uh but okay instead like we said after
rook captures on c8 with bishop to a3 by
fabi he wants to shift the bishop over
to b2 to then uh
add more pressure to the to the g7 pawn
and now comes with rook to c7 now maxime
takes care of the the seven franc so he
will not uh allow any rook lifting
we rook to f4 going after the knight and
now
knight back to f6 and here again the
situation on the clock is not great for
maxim but he's doing okay and we're
already on move 32
so for some 55 minutes uh for fobby and
17 minutes for maxine
so bishop to b2 now just shifting the
bishop to this long diagonal
and now comes knight the e7 uh
problem is you don't really have the
option of starting to push your past
pawn
and it's very hard to do this at any
point
before you actually make proper
preparations because here for example
just bishop captures g
captures uh and rook to d6 now putting
pressure on the pawn and there's a very
little you can do
there's really nothing you can do to
defend against this so instead
after bishop to b2 we have knight the e7
uh
and now comes uh well what fabi had in
mind
it doesn't seem very uh intuitive or
rather
even seems counterintuitive to give up
this beautiful bishop but if it works
uh you have to play it so bishop
captures we have g captures
and now h4 and now comes another very
interesting moment in the game
uh here again if maxim starts pushing
let's say b5 then you again allow some
rook to d6 action attacking this pawn
attacking this spawn
and if knight f5 blocking this rook then
we could have something like captures
and then
uh what uh what are you gonna play here
there's really not all that
much you can do so not really something
to go for so instead maxine plays the
the much better
h5 and this is a really great because uh
in in the future if for example rook
comes to
claim the the fifth rank and you get
this point uh
uh for example h5 would check then the
king will have to go back with
this h5 move uh maxine makes sure that
such a thing never happens
but okay now fabi needs to find a
different idea and
he might make this h5 pawn a target
so rook the g3 with check king to f7 and
now comes
rook the g5 as the f pawn is pinned
makes sense
he will not win the h5 pawn but of
course uh
maxime has something to say about that
rook the c1 with check
king h2 and now knight to g6 attacking
this rook and this spawn
and of course you can't keep defending
this pawn because if the rook moves
anywhere
away from the f file then of course we
can just capture this
rook and g5 so instead rook f2 you have
to keep the pin
pin and now comes knight captures on h4
rook captures an h5 and now just
knight back to g6 you could decide maybe
to defend the knight with knight
with rook to c4 but it's pretty much the
same just g3 knight goes back rook h7
check
and now the king will have to move uh
and after the king moves we're going to
capture this pawn on b7
so it's pretty much the same you don't
really get anything by defending it
so uh we have knights to g6 right away
and
only now rook to h7 with check king to
e6 and now rook captures on b7
so you can see for the past 20 moves
this uh past a and b
pawn were never never really got to
their moment they could never be pushed
so here knight to e5 and now comes rook
to b6 with
check uh preparing to win the other pawn
as well
and here uh fabi went into uh or rather
maksim went into a really really
long thing uh and he had to decide uh
what to do here but also
not that long of a thing fabi had a much
a much longer thing
for this rook to b6 move it was i think
the first
really really long thing of the game it
was over 20 minutes
and he had to calculate precisely so of
course rook to c6
he's blocking this and now rook captures
you could also play something like rook
to b2
and then just keep the pressure with the
idea of captures and then this rook
uh coming to b6 but after king d6 uh it
doesn't really work so you'd have to you
know again
look for something else if captures
captures you don't have rook to b6
so instead after work the c6 fabi just
captures we have captures captures and
then now comes king to g3
we have king to f7 and now comes rook to
c2
now the knight will have to move we're
going to attack it again and then we're
going to go after the a6 pawn so here
knight to b4 attacking the ro the rook
here and now
of course rook to d2 so what do you play
here
knights to c6 and now we play uh
king to f4 and it's very interesting uh
it's uh
uh you you definitely have winning
chances with white here as long as the
the pawn is on g2 as something magnus
said as he's also one of the
commentators in the chess 24's live just
24 lives
live streaming uh but if this pawn was
for example on g4
uh then it would be it would be bad
because you could at some point
sacrifice your knight for this pawn
which is not something
that uh you want to allow all right or
not sacrifice it you would uh
you would force either the white rook or
the white king to you know stay back and
help out with the defending of the pawn
so king to f4
and now comes king to g6 we rook to d6
finally attacking this knight
knight to e5 and now we finally
eliminated the pawn with rook captures
on a6
and now rook to f7 and now black needs
to
defend this constantly and he can't
allow white to enter the position for
example if they
if this king touches f5 uh then it's
gonna be it's gonna be very scary uh one
idea is something like rook a3 to g3 and
then you
you push uh push back the king but
that's why
the knight is very nicely placed here
because you can always block with
something like
knight the knight to g5 so here we have
king to e4 and now knight to h6
so what do you play here uh instead of
knights to h6 which
might not be all that great knights the
e5 was also a possibility but
um again it's very hard to say uh for
example rook to a8
knight back to f7 we're gonna go rook to
g8 with check king h7
and now rook to g4 and now what do you
play here knight d6
check king d5 and now we we enter the
position and we
we win the game so you know not uh you
have to be extremely precise here and if
this is a win
then this is a table base winning if
it's a draw it's a table based draw
uh so you know very very difficult stuff
so after king to e4 we have knight to
the h6 by maxine
and now comes uh rook to a5
so knight back to f7 and now only now
rook to a3 we have knight to d6 with
czech king f4 and not knight to f5 very
important guarding the g3 square so no
knight
sono rook to g3 check is possible uh we
have rook to d3
a nice waiting move and now again maxine
uh repeats with knight to h6 and this is
uh
this is not good he should have gone for
knight to g7
this is the correct square and then from
there you will you will be able to
defend but now knight to h6
he allows rook to g3 check for fabi king
to f7
and now now comes king to e4
and this is well this is very strong uh
moving the rook
and then trying to harass the black king
from this side might be a little bit
easier but
you know who knows i i don't think uh i
i think uh
maxine had to believe that this is a
table-based draw and fabi had to believe
that this is a table-based win
even though uh by the by the uh you know
by the sheer amount of moves that was
played in this game
i don't think that was uh that was the
case uh but okay
king the e4 and now comes knight the g8
uh just trying trying to stay in the
game uh problem is if you play something
like king to
fade then rook the g6 is very strong
attacking both
knight and the pawn and if something
like uh
knights the g8 then king f5 and then
again you've allowed uh the white king
to claim the
the f5 square so instead after uh king
to e4
knight to g8 by maxine uh and now comes
king to
f5 finally uh again it's uh
it's a very tricky position probably uh
something like rook to a3 is a bit more
straightforward but again
it's it's very hard to to this you know
even decipher why
i will show one line that's really good
for white for example knight e7 we're
gonna pin the knight
rook a7 and now if king a6 now we're
gonna go king f3 and now
basically now we need to touch the h5
square and then everything is going our
way king f7
we're going to go rook g4 now doesn't
really matter king e6 king h5 king f7
and now
king h6 we're gonna go king e6 g
for now taking away the f5 square uh and
now
doesn't really matter or rather uh if uh
instead of this
we go something like into g7 then knight
to f5 check and then we have to go back
we haven't really achieved anything
so g4 is much better and then after king
to f7
now we play king the h7 king to e6 and
now king to g7
and now after a move like knight to d5
we're gonna play rook the a6 check
king to e7 and now rook to a5 we kick
away the defender of the f6 pawn
and finally after the knight moves now
two more checks rook a7 check king e6
rook a6 check and the f6 pawn finally
falls king e5 rook captures here
and that's it now the now the game is
winning but it really takes a lot
to win this pawn uh but instead of this
instead of uh rook to a3 or something
like that
we have uh king to f5 immediately and
this is uh
a bit more difficult maxine goes knight
to e7 check
king f4 and not knight to d5 check
and now comes king to g4 uh king to f5
again you should you should probably try
king f5 back and then if king is seven
chicken king to e4 and then go for this
exact same idea uh because now it's
going to be uh
much more difficult so after knight d5
check we have king to g4
and king to g6 now not allowing of
course the white king to touch
h5 or f5 so king of three check king
back to f7
and now king to e4 fabi will try again
of course
uh and here we have knight the e7 and
this seems to be one of the one of the
only one of the mistakes in the game uh
where you know it's
very hard to even uh claim that a move
is a mistake
but uh you know such are such are the
the games where
uh we can't really learn uh i mean
if these guys don't know what this is
and how
how this is played precisely then i
don't know who does but here for example
knight to c7
ensures a table based draw however
knight the e7
uh the move maxine thought does as
probably he thought that this was enough
uh that does not ensure a draw so here
king f4 by fabi knight to d5 check
king to f5 we have knights the e7 check
king back to e4
uh and now knights the g8 by maxine
we have rook to h3 by fabi king to g6
and now finally rook back to a3
king to f7 and now king to f4 uh we
ignite the h6
and now rook to g3 we have knight back
to g8
now comes king to g4 and now we are
definitely
claiming this uh h5 square the problem
is
uh if king to g6 now then king h4 check
and you have to take care of the knight
you have to go back and then we win the
h5 square
and we know that if uh our king touches
h5 then then it then it's a winning end
game
so instead after king to g4 we have
knights the e7
and now comes king to h5 uh we have
knights to d5 now
uh hoping for some knight f4 check ideas
but now rook to f3 fabi just eliminates
all of these ideas with king to e6
and now g4 and g4 was very
very uh impressive by fabi because if it
doesn't work then you're just uh
throwing the game away
but he shows that he can calculate very
very precisely even after playing for
like
uh five and a half hours and he finds
the
the the the correct idea so here uh
point is if you go back let's say king
f7 just king h6
if 97 we just go g5 remember
that the f pawn is pinned uh and if we
again let's
go here to defend this we just advance
g6 check king g8 now rook b3 and that's
it we cannot
move the knight because all of these
squares are covered if the knight moves
this is just gonna be checkmate
so instead after g4 we have king to e5
but now
fabi just plays king to g6 and he was in
this position
on move 74 that maksim bashir lagrav
resigned the game and that means
fabiano caruana catches up to maksim
vashila grav
and if you remember the standings from
the uh first part of the tournament
fabi had three and a half points max
team had four and a half uh he was
sharing first place with janine ponnishi
now fabi also has four and a half points
and he definitely
is catching up to the leaders we're
gonna show at least one more game uh to
see
uh where the the standings are headed so
we're not gonna discuss the standings
uh over round eight uh just yet but
we're gonna
do it at the end of all the games that
are shown
uh so really really impressive stuff by
fabi uh
very very uh excruciating uh end game
but
the the opening and the middle game were
you know
i like like watching a movie i mean
after this uh sorry
after this uh idea that fabi
fabi found you know just c3 first a new
move and then already he shows what the
idea was
c3 bishop c5 and then bishop c4 amazing
stuff and
this is uh this is what it takes the to
take down maxime when maxime goes for
the sicilian defense you can't just play
anything maxim knows everything
and even here where fabi caught him off
guard uh maxine
uh i mean he defended everything
uh it took him a lot of time but he
found all of the correct ideas and all
of the right moves and it's very
uh i i did not think that he would lose
this but fabi is a machine fabi is the
second highest
rated chess player in the world and if
you give him you know a little bit of
hope he will you know
bite down onto that and he will uh he
will see it through
uh but it was a it was an incredibly
incredibly exciting game and you know
really really awesome uh one one moment
where i think
maybe it could have uh gone differently
uh was uh here when uh maxime decided to
go for this knight the e4 idea
uh where he didn't just try and try and
hold on to everything with rook to a7
maybe it would be i i don't think fabi
would go for the
uh for the for the draw like like we
mentioned i think fabio would probably
continue playing but
uh uh who knows uh maybe he thought okay
this is a bit too passive now the rook
is here none of my pieces are developed
uh maybe it is a bit
too dangerous and i'm sure he made the
correct um you know the practical idea
uh but who knows maybe maybe he even
thought that uh you know the the rook
sacrifice here was
the exchange sacrifice here was the way
to go and then he can just start pushing
his pawns
but as you've seen those pawns never
really had a chance
uh so after this really really wild game
after move uh 74 uh he uh he resigned as
there is nothing more to be done here
problem is if you go for something like
knight f4 check let's say king h6 you're
gonna go king e4 attack the rook rook f1
doesn't really matter king to e5 uh
we're just gonna
go king g7 the pawn is now it will being
very very much threatened if knight here
with check we can go king f7
and that's it once we block with knight
f4 we're just gonna play rook the e1
check you can't go here you can't go
here you have to move back king d6 will
win the pawn
and now that we've won the pawn it's
just a very very easy win
so really really amazing stuff and
definitely a great turn of events for
fabi
as he now has uh well great great
chances
of winning the candidates tournament and
challenging magnus for
for the title uh second time uh in a row
so we'll see what happens
uh stay tuned and you know uh sorry
about a very long video but this was a
very very long game
uh so yeah hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank anforio martino
philip gleason david kimura and the mr
hoodie guy for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day